Super Bowl comes with super
opportunities for local businesses some
Las Vegas leaders just announced two
chair subcommittees that will help get
these businesses to the NFL Ryan Matthey
with more on the update plans for the
big game
the businesses down here Peter Guzman
already helps to promote small Hispanic
owned businesses as Latin Chamber of
Commerce CEO we're kind of the liaison
to the community and the NFL this year
he's also co-chair of a subcommittee
Community Affairs for the Las Vegas
Super Bowl its economic impact its
opportunities for those who can provide
goods and services and have the capacity
to do that we want to put them in line
to be able to do that 11 subcommittees
announced this week made up of over 300
local leaders helping to logistically
plan hotel accommodations Public Safety
transportation and most everything else
for the big game and to do that they
need the help of those who already work
here small businesses
expected to receive lasting impacts
beyond the big game
the stadium fits 65 000. hotel rooms
restaurants spending spending spending
but up to 450 000 people expected in
town for it says host committee CEO Sam
Joffrey it's also that event that every
other event looks at to say oh if Vegas
could host Super Bowl then they can host
Maya that meaning more business for
local businesses just hosting the game
expected to bring in at least 700
million dollars they had a goal you
might get it to a billion potential that
Las Vegas Convention and visitor
Authority CEO Stephen Hill says we'll
leave participating businesses better
off than they were our reputation is
growing and improving because we're able
to host the biggest events in the world
that benefits everybody here whether
you're directly involved with that or
not
so the Super Bowl business connect
program closed its application window
actually just this month over 200 local
businesses that will support aspects of
the game and the events leading up to it
will be announced next month